[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 los
padres de casi dos tercios de todos los
niños del mundo no tienen derecho a una
licencia de paternidad remunerada las
labores de cuidado siguen siendo
asignadas en la mayoría de países a las
madres y sin crianza compartida pues
aumenta la brecha de género casi 90
millones de niños menores de un año
viven en 92 países donde no existe la
obligación legal de dar a los padres de
tiempo para cuidarlos ellos pierden su
derecho y su deber de ejercer una
paternidad integral y sin su presencia
las mujeres se tienen menos
oportunidades de recuperarse física y
emocionalmente del parto y se quedan
rezagadas profesionalmente
el fondo de naciones unidas para la
infancia unicef e recomienda que
aumenten los tiempos de licencia como
una forma efectiva de proteger a la
primera infancia los países que no dan
licencias están en rojo de naranja
aquellos que otorgan en menos de tres
semanas en amarillo a aquellos que
brindan hasta 13 semanas y en verde los
pocos se quedan 14 semanas o más en baja
parental los padres tendrían tiempo para
cuidar y crear vínculos con su bebé
disminuye la probabilidad de violencia
intrafamiliar y se beneficia la igualdad
de género
vamos a ver un ejemplo porque en el
mundo 109 países ofrecen alguna forma de
permiso con remuneración pero el tiempo
con los hijos varía mucho y en la
mayoría de casos no es suficiente entre
las naciones con mejores condiciones
están alemania finlandia islandia
noruega suecia y corea del sur mientras
que la mayoría de latinos ofrecen en
promedio 10 días recientemente españa dé
un paso adelante desde el primero de
enero los dos padres se tienen derecho a
16 semanas de permiso intransferibles y
remuneradas al 100% un avance que pone
al país como pionero en el tema para la
igualdad de género veamos el informe por
el list gas en gel y mos but in
el sayed y que esperan su segundo hijo y
ya saben que esta vez podrán gozar de
los cuatro primeros meses juntos en casa
desde el inicio de 2021 en españa ambos
progenitores tienen 16 semanas 4 meses
de permiso paternidad que muy delgados
al 100% e intransferibles una noticia
que celebra la futura madre a nivel
emocional como mujer te sientes como
mujer que está materna no te sientes más
acompañada tienes a tu pareja al lado
que te ve porque está pasando no estás
sola todo el día la pareja recuerda lo
difícil que fue con el nacimiento de su
primer hijo cuando ella tuvo que volver
al trabajo yo me acuerdo quién me decía
es que menos estoy perdida no estoy
perdido porque había empezado a bajar
como me estoy perdiendo que haya
empezado a tirar el plátano por el suelo
me estoy perdiendo que se ha dado la
vuelta
en través de melancolía si al final nos
olvidamos de qué es lo importante en la
vida entonces te pasan la vida diciendo
qué
que evolucionar prueba profesionalmente
pero nadie te habla de lo que hay que
cerrar que lo que importa realmente qué
es esto
para la plataforma pine a que luchó
durante años para obtener estos permisos
esta equiparación de garantiza más
igualdad del mercado laboral pero
también haga evolucionar las
mentalidades los permisos de iguales
intransferibles de nacimiento de opción
a nivel legal favorecen ese cambio y esa
transformación en los hombres el modelo
tradicional de los hombres
podríamos decir el machismo tradicional
que lo vemos como normal pero según la
asociación esta ley todavía puede
mejorar deja la solicitud del permiso a
las 16 semanas a negociar con la empresa
y entonces claro el empresario o la
empresaria puede decir que no le parece
bien la petición del trabajador con
estos permisos españa se ha convertido
en un país pionero en la materia por
delante del resto de países europeos
vamos a conversar del tema la invitada
de hoy es virginia carrera portavoz de
la plataforma por permisos iguales e
intransferibles espina que como vimos
trabajó muchos años para alcanzar este
avance virginia bienvenida de ella soy y
comienzo preguntándole por qué una
licencia de más tiempo para los padres
puede ser transformadora socialmente y
porque de 16 semanas ese tiempo es
suficiente nosotras desde la plataforma
que llevamos reivindicando la
equiparación del permiso de 2005
entendemos que el equilibrio el reparto
del cuidado falsa porque los permisos
sean los mismos para padres y madres no
hay tres cuestiones muy claras que
generarían este van a generar la
equiparación del permiso la primera es
que eliminamos los roles de ejemplo
puesto que ambos padres madre madre
padre el padre o madre para de cuidar y
a nuestros importantísimo evidenciamos
que ambos progenitores pueden cuidar en
segundo lugar potenciamos el valor
cuidador de los varones que han de tener
permiso anteriormente no les hemos da la
posibilidad de cuidar y en tercer lugar
estamos estudiando el etiqueta del menos
disponible para las mujeres en el mundo
laboral los servicios son las cuidadoras
en exclusiva
tres cuestiones lo que necesitamos es
que avancemos hacia un modelo de
sociedad equilibrado en el que todas las
personas cuidan o las personas trabajan
bueno recientemente el partido
ciudadanos anunció la intención de
extender las licencias parentales a 24
semanas para el 2024 usted ve que esto
sea factible lo primero de todo nosotros
nos hablamos de que nos esperan las
licencias lo que hablamos es que el
tratamiento tiene que ser que retirarnos
tiene que ser igualitario y así
avanzamos una intención único para las
madres ya los padres no volvemos a
mantener la destinación que existe por
ejemplo en el mercado de trabajo cuando
me sentí que tan de mano de obra de
riesgo nos concentramos y además está
muy como sólo un permiso pues estamos
dando la oportunidad de cuidar a un
progenitor porque tiene que existir en
primer lugar es una equiparación el
permiso ambos progenitores genera el
mismo 8 por además apostamos porque la
simultaneidad igual apreciar a las
familias y son un poco las que venga
bien a los progenitores dependiendo su
situación no es lo mismo tener un poco
tener dos aunque tener tres hijas es lo
primero que plantea el debate en
términos de aumento no tendrá que
aumentar separa ambos progenitores
porque la garantía
y ese equilibrio se equilibre perdón la
situación que tenemos de diferencias de
de cuidados y dedicaciones de cuidado en
esta sociedad pasa porque todo es una de
las dos puedan trabajar la clave estaría
entre sí realmente españa demanda un
permiso más amplio más elevado de tiempo
sea para ambos progenitores para las
madres y para los padres no solamente
para los padres porque lo eliminaremos
entonces o bien decías tú o sea brecha
de género que existe porque no estás
somos las principales cuidadoras
estamos etiquetadas así y por tanto no
accedemos ni igualdad al mercado de
trabajo eso es súper clave porque es
justamente ahí donde se encuentra
prácticamente el origen de la brecha de
género y hacen que la mujer como tiene
asignada la tarea de cuidado
culturalmente se queda rezagada en otras
áreas de su desarrollo personal y
profesional y el hombre continúa
avanzando entonces tenemos dos estigmas
primero el que la mujer es la que tiene
que cuidar a los hijos cuando se toma
esa decisión en la familia y el segundo
estigma es que la mujer no tiene la
misma capacidad de concentración o de
rendimiento laboral precisamente por la
maternidad
teniendo esos dos estigmas en cuenta
para mi siguiente pregunta a la larga
las licencias de más duración para
madres y padres van a golpear la
economía o por el contrario la van a
beneficiar y además es que un bebé mejor
cuidado va a ser más sano papas van a
tener más tiempo para criar y podríamos
presumir que también van a rendir mejor
en el trabajo porque queremos eliminar
con la doble presencia que vivimos las
mujeres constantemente el mundo laboral
lo de fuera de casa y lo de dentro de
casa no es la doble presencia que nos
permite en muchos casos tener que
nuestros riesgos sociales o
psicosociales bueno pues si bien en
cualquier evaluación de riesgos en el
puesto de trabajo pero la pregunta que
me hace respecto al tema de la
ampliación nuestra plataforma que es una
plataforma de reivindicación única lo
que plantea es que hay que repartir el
cuidado y hay que repartirlo en igualdad
no vale el permiso sea transferible para
el segundo progenitor y no vale que uno
de los dos cuide más porque antes no
eliminamos la división sexual del
trabajo y por lo tanto no abordamos una
de las demandas clásicas del feminismo
que es que hombres y mujeres tienen que
tener las mismas oportunidades y el
mismo trato nuestra demanda es una
demanda feminista
y plantea que cualquier pareja que
quiera tener una criatura tenga el mismo
derecho a cuidar y el mismo derecho de
trabajar entonces la cuestión de que va
a garantizar mayor salud mental y mayor
productividad a las empresas cuando se
reparte eso está garantizado porque no
solo va a estar la organización familiar
en la cabeza de las mujeres para ver un
reparto de más los estudios de los
países que llevan trabajando más tiempo
el equilibrio en los permisos nos dicen
que se reparten los roles y más que se
reparte los roles los roles se comparten
y que además se toma las decisiones en
mayor unidad por eso la clave de nuestra
propuesta es que la equilibrio parte de
que todas las personas cuiden con las
personas trabajen y aquí en españa la
equiparación del permiso que es pionera
nos va a garantizar un caminito una
senda para que hasta ahora que habíamos
sido las mujeres las únicas es casi en
exclusiva descuidábamos eliminemos esta
etiqueta y para que ellos entren a
formar parte del mercado laboral pero
también del cuidado ello siempre está el
mercado laboral no está siempre hemos
estado cuidando todas queremos cuidar
todas queremos trabajar todos deben
cuidar y tienen que cuidar y todos
quieren trabajar nos gustan las mujeres
en este programa sabemos que nos vendría
muy bien bajarle un poco a la presión de
la mujer que tiene que ser perfecta y
solamente cumple con todo lo que se
espera de ella socialmente si bien puede
desarrollarse profesionalmente pero
además maneja a la perfección todas las
labores del hogar y entonces le voy a
pedir que hablemos de salud unicef dice
que la interacción positiva con madres y
con padres desde el nacimiento ayuda al
crecimiento del cerebro de los niños y
ayuda para su desarrollo en la vida
incluso para que tengan mayor salud y
para que sea más fácil el aprendizaje y
esto es importante para una europa que
busca asegurar la salud de sus nuevas
generaciones más ahora que los
ciudadanos se lo piensan mucho más antes
de asumir el ser padres mira me encanta
gracias apreciación angela porque
realmente el modelo que nosotras venimos
planteando parte de que la criatura
cuanto más tiempo este cuidado por
alguno de sus dos progenitores pues más
posibilidades tienes para proteger su
salud y evidentemente para su propia
crianza no hay para la sensación de
cuidado que tiene alguien que cuanto más
tiempo pasa con sus dos padres
su hogar también se va a desarrollar no
sólo es una cuestión de unicef la
constitución española o reconoce la
protección al menor y este permiso que
nosotros planteamos que debe ser
disfrutado de manera no simultánea es
decir el tiempo necesario para las
familias dos semanas o los que ellos
decidan pero obligatoriamente dos
semanas pueden ser simultáneas el resto
pueden ser de manera continua primero un
progenitor la madre por ejemplo y
segundo el padre no hay garantizaríamos
más tiempo de cuidado más tiempo de
crianza directa o del día a día por uno
de los dos progenitores y esto
garantizaría mejorarse la salud mejoras
en todo lo que tiene que ver con la
creación de la figura del apego hacia
los padres y las madres y también no nos
olvidemos generaríamos un modelo de
sociedad en el que se vería desde
temprana edad cualquier criatura que su
papá y su mamá cuidan por igual y eso es
clave para romper con los roles de
género yo creo que también son las
cuestiones que nuestra plataforma ha
venido reivindicando rompa algunos roles
de género acabemos con ellos
en segundo lugar dejemos que los hombres
cuiden con su permiso propio en tercer
lugar
dejemos que las mujeres puedan acceder
en igualdad del mercado de trabajo
porque ya no son las etiquetadas como
súper mujeres trabajo y casa todos
tenemos una casa de todos tenemos un
trabajo todas
una casa todos tienen un trabajo
bueno pues se nos acaba el tiempo pero
la gran conclusión debe romperse la
inequidad y la brecha de género y para
eso tiene que haber una crianza integral
e igualitaria de mamá y papá gracias a
usted por estar con nosotros y sigan en
france24 nos vemos próximamente en ellas
hoy
[Música]